il a promis aux canadiens des jours
meilleurs
de l'ouverture du changement un
renouveau si le 23e premier ministre
veut incarner cette image mois justin pj
trudeau je jure solennellement il tenait
surtout à ce que son conseil des
ministres en soit le reflet
cela commence par sa nouvelle ministre
de la justice jodi white ribbon avocate
et ex chef régional de l'assemblée des
premières nations incarnent la diversité
du nouveau cabinet tout comme hard gidza
jean ex policier et militaire à la
retraite nouveau ministre de la défense
et myriam moncef une réfugiée afghane
qui sera responsable de la réforme
démocratique promise par justin trudeau
d'autres nouveaux visages se voit aussi
confier d'importantes responsabilités
4une mais cana à l'environnement et au
changement climatique qu'elle fait aux
anciens combattants
l'athlète paralympique carla quand tout
sera responsable des sports et des
personnes handicapées des affaires
étrangères mais justin trudeau mise
aussi sur l'expérience en faisant de
stéphane dion son ministre des affaires
étrangères
d'autres vétérans accède également au
cabinet rohff goudé est là la sécurité
publique john né car l'homme à
l'immigration et aux réfugiés pour
l'équipe économique
un mélange de nouveautés et d'expérience
la recrue belmont l'eau devient ministre
des finances flanqué du vétéran scott
brian ou conseil du trésor
christian friedel élu lors d'une
partielle en 2013 s'occupera de commerce
international autre stéphane dion cinq
autres québécois tiennent une place à la
table du conseil des ministres en
atlantique
dominic leblanc ami d'enfance de justin
trudeau est largement responsable de la
victoire libérale dans cette région
devient leader du gouvernement en
chambre
trente nouveaux ministres trente
nouveaux visages et autant de femmes que
d'hommes comme l'avait promis le chef
libéral
on est en 2015 aujourd'hui je crois que
d'avoir un cabinet qui est le reflet du
canada dans tout ça
magnifique diversité
c'est une société une priorité pour moi
est un engagement
nous voulons mériter la confiance des
canadiens et pour cela nous allons
démontrer que nous avons confiance dans
l'est canadien justin trudeau on veut
souligner le contraste avec
l'administration précédente et promet
plus d'accès plus d'ouverture plus de
transparence aussi tant pour le public
que pour la presse
il s'est également réservé le
portefeuille des relations
intergouvernementales pour montrer
l'importance des liens qu'il compte
entretenir avec ses homologues
provinciaux et si daniel thibault radio
canada